I'm Ashley Judd and I'm heading off to
India where a growing hiv/aids emergency
poses a vicious threat to as the global
ambassador for youth AIDS it is my
mission to see how HIV is moving into
the general population to confront the
unique risks faced by India's girls and
women and then to use my Hollywood
connections to enlist Bollywood's
biggest stars to help turn the tide in
the war against hiv/aids a war where
awareness and a willingness to act truly
make the difference between life and
death for millions hiv/aids has orphaned
no fewer than 15 million children
worldwide and I was about to meet two
beautiful young sisters who would show
me vividly what that really means these
two young girls lost both their parents
abruptly to hiv/aids presently they live
with a brother and aunt and a
grandmother in a small home luckily the
children are not infected with HIV but
even so life for Neelam and KOMO is far
from easy
so you're 14 yes in year 12 and one its
Ziegfeld who is 6 years old so a little
little brother yeah okay where is he oh
good
why aren't you at school you go to night
school and why do you go to night school
they might come to school do you work
you're 14 years old and you work when
you support your brother and your
sisters my goodness that's a lot for a
little group it must be really hard but
I'm glad you go how much do you earn
1200 rupees a week a month a month Holy
Mary Mother of God and is that enough
for you to feed yourself and your
siblings Neelam is very vulnerable
that's actually here I go again that's
the most hysterical guy cut on the strip
just thinking about how well she is ripe
for the picking she is exactly the child
who gets sold she lives in a poor
neighborhood with men who were poor who
would sell her in a heartbeat
she is so vulnerable do you think you
look like your mother are your dad ready
think you look like your daddy how about
you you look like your mommy they're
beautiful would you be open to telling
me a little bit about what it was like
for you
when you found out they were sick I'm
local I said we should stay like a mommy
oh why so sick bag okay what about
you honey that you do I can promise you
that I will never forget you and I will
always pray for you and I will do my
part to make sure that girls like you
can be educated and can be empowered and
can realize your dreams and live to your
fulfillment that's my part
it is my most earnest wish that I could
do something to help everyone like
Neelam and Como something that could
make a positive change in their lives
now rather than later